as the shutdown drags on backed by the
work-from-home elitists on TV the
majority of Americans who can't make a
living from their laptop screaming what
do we have to do to get our leaders to
follow the data and the science here's
the data 21% of New York City residents
have had coronavirus nearly half a
million in Los Angeles in Santa Clara
County California up to 85 times more
people have had it than the official
statistics claimed the fatality rate
therefore is not the 3.4 percent or 2%
or 1% we were told it's closer to naught
point 1 percent yes seasonal flu just
more contagious that's why it comes in a
rush why we had to flatten the curve and
slow the spread but we did that so why
are we still shot down here's the
science viruses don't disappear because
we stay at home they keep going until
there's not enough people left to infect
a vaccine is over a year away they say
but millions of Americans have already
had the virus most didn't know they had
it 80% have mild or zero symptoms that's
more than you can say for the victims of
the shutdown
there's the toll rising every day and
here's what our leaders think about it
economic hardship yes very bad not death
emotional stress from being locked in a
house very bad not death domestic
violence on the increase very bad not
death have you ever heard anything so
callous or stupid economic hardship
causes death here's what else causes
death millions of medical procedures
canceled because of wildly inaccurate
coronavirus projections just one example
in the state of Arkansas recently 80
people in hospital with coronavirus
8,000 empty beds this insanity has to
stop we know whose most vulnerable and
how to protect them 20% of you
coronavirus deaths are in nursing homes
in some states it's over half so what
are our leaders doing about that they're
making it worse for weeks New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo instead of sending
nursing home coronavirus patients to the
nearly empty Navy hospital ship sent
them back into nursing homes with that
one
demented decision he's responsible for a
big part of America's death toll we know
who's at risk and how to protect them
why aren't our leaders surging medical
capacity and equipment to our nursing
homes and care facilities where the
greatest generation is so obviously
vulnerable I'll tell you why because
they're too busy putting sand in skate
parks flying creepy surveillance drones
and worst of all hiring armies of
busybody contact tracers
to implement this idiotic unscientific
reckless establishment groupthink that
the only way we can open up is
widespread testing contact tracing and
isolating we need to test we need to
isolate those who test positive we then
need to contact trace we cannot truly
reopen the economy without widespread
testing testing and testing contact
tracing testing contact tracing
different forms of testing antibody
testing you know testing people are
asymptomatic in order to get the country
back to work MSNBC had a two hour
special this week entirely based on this
misinformation it was literally called
testing and the road to reopening
testing contact tracing and isolating
are great if you're trying to contain an
outbreak at the start where you have
hundreds of cases it is totally absurd
after a pandemic with millions infected
where you'll miss most of them anyway
because they have no symptoms and the
absurdity rises to a level of grave
danger if you're making this a condition
for reopening knowing that every day you
delay will kill more Americans last week
we set out questions for dr. pouchy well
he may not care about being accountable
to you but our state and local leaders
do listen to him he's the one that
started this nonsense still using an old
playbook even though the facts have
changed I beg you dr. Falchi tell the
governors tell
Mayers how to protect the vulnerable in
our nursing homes who are dying in
droves because of inadequate infection
control tell them that if we properly
protect the vulnerable we don't need the
costly complicated technocratic
nightmare of testing and contact tracing
and tell the American people so
terrified by months of misinformation
that many are scared to go out even if
states do reopen tell them that most
Americans according to the data have
nothing to fear from coronavirus that
there is no scientific basis as long as
we properly protect the vulnerable for
this shutdown the mindset of the
shutdown zealots is the opposite of
science instead of adapting their
thinking in the light of new information
they cling to their old position despite
new information it's not science its
ideology it's not based on data but
Dogma doctor Falchi tell the world that
based on the data based on the sides we
must protect the vulnerable end the
shutdown and save lives now